noi siamo la conseguenza di quello che
ci viene fatto il riflesso la condizione
del mondo l'uomo vincerà quando smetterà
di essere con il suonato da se stesso
tutto scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo tutto
scorre
scorre veloce con il tempo tutto si
spiega per fronti e per detti ecco che
si parla delle donne come oggetti scorre
scorre muta l'opinione donna uguale
islam velo costrizione forse una
semplice unica opinione alla società
punta il dito su una sola religione
queste verità e non opinione afferma il
politico di turno in televisione mentre
genti e popoli vengono discriminati tace
il mondo e vengono ignorati intanto gli
occhi della gente cambiano pensa al
bambino che guarda il telegiornale pensa
sul futuro la sua morale seriale pensa
che il pensiero di uno è muta la società
e la paura cresce cresce crescerà
ricorda le mie rime ricorda le mie
lacrime informati meglio non fare la
stem io la stem e di conoscenza che
riempie la coscienza perché
tutto scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo tutto
scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo paura
ho paura passa per le menti genti e
popoli pieni di fraudolenti nulla è
impossibile dare per scontato tutto è un
mezzo che condiziona l'apparato tutto si
crea con un fine all inizio la marea di
tempo pieno di pregiudizio ipocrisie
razzismo si nascondono si camuffano
libertà diritti umani essi si giustifica
vedi i miei occhi senti le mie parole
semplici giochi gli effetti di colore
colore che identificano la mia
personalità piena di sfumature e di
sincerità compongo la mia essenza la mia
femminilità
ma che cos'è che spaventa di questo mio
velo la forma il peso o il mistero
ricorda le mie rime ricorda le mie
lacrime informati meglio non fare la
stem io assieme di conoscenza ma che
riempie la coscienza perché
tutto scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo tutto
scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo cambia
cambia in ogni momento facendo diventare
tutto un tormento poiché terrorizzando i
cuori della gente puntando sui media
sull'ultimo potente non farti ingannare
dalle bugie dette in media team fluence
con falsità indirette ritorna nella mia
mente quel ricordo recente che spaventa
la mente di ogni credente credenti che
vedono il passato di un momento il segno
che segna l'inizio di uno spegnimento
ormai si insegna solo di indicare 11
settembre si iniziò ricordare giorno
dell'islam violento che spaventa e crea
un gran turbamento ormai sanno solo
parlare ma non bisogna tacere
no no non bisogna tacere
tutto scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo tutto
scorre
tutto scorre veloce con il tempo
e vedi di volare che il mondo lo
vogliamo cambiare siamo noi il futuro di
questo paese e mezzo il mare lo squalo
non è uno ma è internazionale
tu vedi quegli occhi che riempiono il
cielo la family spaventa senza limpido
senza freno ma tanto le risposte sono
tante la gente il potente fa finta di
niente perché si ha paura di rinunciare
ad un male l'egoismo alla fame ea
rottame spaventa di te stesso e non del
mondo perché sei tu a renderlo un
semplice sfondo di un mondo